hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast on
Monday July 17 2017 what's going on how
why yeah July 17 2017 I'm going to go
play that number remember that [ __ ]
maybe you still do it always remember
that it's all of a sudden you know
somebody got something like a receipt or
something and there was a couple of the
same numbers that's what I'm going to
play I'm going to go down there and play
it on the megabucks that's what they had
in Massachusetts megabucks my favorite
one best name ever for any lottery I
thought was set for life that was just
the perfect phrase every blue-collar
working stiff that's what they want to
just [ __ ] set for life just sitting
there having a [ __ ] beer Chex rolling
in don't got to worry about nothing set
for life right because if you're working
class you you you work paycheck to
paycheck and it becomes a [ __ ] grind
sets the life dude I could [ __ ] sit
right here right I could [ __ ] sit
right here - just [ __ ] stared at my
[ __ ] toes and I still got that check
on it every month for the rest of my
life you know why kid because I'm set
for life hear about Mikey Dodie hit the
[ __ ] set for life he's [ __ ] set
for life kid doesn't have to do [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
god bless him anyways I'm in a great
goddamn mood why because I got in our
sleep last night despite the fact my
just waking up and she's trying out her
voice now when she sits remember when
Mariah Carey used to hit those really
high notes she's doing that and every
time I look over like oh my god she's
just looking at me and she has like her
legs and everything's like up in the air
and she's smiling at you it's like
impossible to get upset you just start
left
it's actually ripping about that this
weekend in Grand Rapids school now what
if that works as an adult you cut
somebody off in traffic and they look
over you if you somehow flexible enough
we could just put both arms and both
legs in the air just give them that
[ __ ] baby grin that might have been
the creepiest image I've ever ever
thought of there you go
it would just creep them out be like oh
my god like I even be driving I think
there's something wrong with them and a
mental Department they're so anyways I
want to thank everybody that came out to
the the shows at the fountain Street
Church in Grand Rapids Michigan it is an
it is continuing to be one of my
favorite gigs I've ever done I know I
always say I'm going to put up pictures
like I didn't put up a picture of my
drumkit like I said it was going to and
I'll tell you why because you know I got
these simple stands and the ones that I
want I just wanted the single bracket
ones I don't like those double bracket
like I'm going to go play in a [ __ ]
hurricane they weigh 9,000 goddamn
pounds I accidentally ordered those
instead of the ones I wanted so I had to
return those and now today I'm going to
pick up the right ones I just want to
have it all set up when you see it I
want you to see it right I wanted to
have the [ __ ] right look I'm not
going to have it like you know here's
the car I bought in I don't have this
build a [ __ ] the tires on it so
but speaking of drums my booking agent
my Reuben Kincaid is uh you know tell
them how much fun I have when I go on
the road if I find a place where I can
go play drums he goes you know we could
put it in your writer that you know
anytime you do a couple nights at a
theater they could set up a drum kit
there I go get the [ __ ] out of here that
sounds like some diva [ __ ] because then
he goes do think they have music acts
there all the time
it's no big deal so I was like alright
so I show up at the fountain Street
Church and they had a [ __ ] beta this
Yamaha kid with this [ __ ] horrific
white trash like leopard skin rap I
don't know what I don't know what to
call it it was like somewhere between
the stray cats way back in the day
and poison maybe you know it actually
looked like the [ __ ] stretchy pants
that the [ __ ] girls would wear they
have your mental concert it was the same
kind of print and I'm looking at those
things going like what the [ __ ] of these
and she goes don't worry everybody
always says that sit down and play and
the kick sounded amazing and I was able
to thanks to my drum teacher you know I
have a game plan when I try to tune
something up and I got this snare to
sound great and I went and known them
[ __ ] hilarious I go in there on
Saturday to play like about an hour
before the doors open so I went in there
and I was [ __ ] whaling on him and
when I got off the kick I you know I was
literally like in like the place where
the priest dresses and [ __ ] you know
puts on all the [ __ ] flowing Poncho's
and [ __ ] and I walked out and there was
no one in the church and I walked in the
parking lot it was like [ __ ] six of
the security guys just standing out
there that's like sorry sorry it was
still would have been great if they
actually had him out on the stage I
would have left them there for the show
wouldn't a bug me but it would have
sounded [ __ ] unbelievable
this giant church and I didn't realize
because you know last time I played
there only played one night it kind of
came in town I did it I was like what
the hell was that that was [ __ ]
incredible and then I left but this time
I you know is it for like two days three
nights and I was able to read up on like
the history of it listen to this [ __ ]
this is all the people that perform
there because there was no bigger venue
that was the biggest venue in the I
guess Western Michigan or whatever or at
least in Grand Rapids so if anybody big
came there they went there everyone
Winston Churchill spoke there Helen
Keller spoke there blind and deaf
learned how to [ __ ] read and write
and speak somehow figure that one out
who else Amelia Earhart Malcolm X
they say Winston Churchill Duke
Ellington Ella Fitzgerald Dave Brubeck
Led Zeppelin Pink Floyd u2 in like 1984
played there I think Zeppelin Pink Floyd
was obviously on their first
tours and that's just that's just what I
can remember trying to picture what I
was looking at the wall who else I saw
there I mean it was [ __ ] incredible
Eleanor Roosevelt and they had like
pictures of them and then like that
little thank-you notes and [ __ ] it was a
[ __ ] ridiculous BB King and then make
I think I said that in the video that I
took which I will actually post I
promise you I'll give you a picture of
my my drumkit
this week so anyways we are on to
episode two of efforts for family we're
recording the first one just remember
this just remember me telling this
recording the first one on July 18 2017
you wait to see how long it takes before
you [ __ ] see it [ __ ] animation
that takes forever but anyways let's let
me talk about a what should I talk about
here about this how about how great
[ __ ] Grand Rapids is and it's one of
my favorite cities I was there with Dean
Del Rey and he was [ __ ] murdering all
week and he had a bunch of fans came out
to people flying in to see him and then
he went on to Detroit to go play some
rock club like after uh after our show
Saturday night but there was this place
of course I post forget the [ __ ] name
of it but they had all these old video
games in there the [ __ ] was it called
and why is my stomach still growling I
had a bowl of cereal trying to stab
myself before the [ __ ] acting gig oh
by the way thank you for all you guys
suggestion sack slash criticism of my
dieting or whatever this guy goes dude
you can't say you're crushing it you
know you crushed it if at night you're
still having a drink or two it's like
Aggie [ __ ] I think I don't realize
that mom yes I realize that but anyways
what was it called Stella's assumption I
can't [ __ ] remember but uh we went
down there and they evidently they had a
great burger which I didn't have went to
this healthy place I've got this [ __ ]
wrap this right you know water water and
then we went oh
because they had all these pinball
machines and [ __ ] me and Deena [ __ ]
oldest [ __ ] we walked in there they only
had one pinball machine but they had all
these great old video games and we
showed up right and we sounded like two
[ __ ] kids D just goes
they got asteroid I think we blew ten
bucks
play in that I've never been one of
those guy never been a video game guy
just haven't been because they're so
[ __ ] awesome they were like addicting
but that is something remember back in
the day when you would watch MTV Cribs
and then like these [ __ ] people would
have these video games in there in their
houses and isalways think like I always
feel like you buy those and then you
never [ __ ] use them like you use it
for like the first day and then it's
just like oh wait I got to go to work
you know I have to work so I can pay for
this big giant stupid machine that I
could have just pumped a couple of
quarters into and let somebody else own
and deal with the [ __ ] maintenance
however if I was ever going to buy one
it would be asteroids and my number two
is a game that not a lot of people know
about and I think for the most part
they've all disappeared it was a [ __ ]
great game at least I loved it it was
called elevators and it was basically a
Glee remember it was like spy versus spy
kind of thing you were dressed in white
and all the bad guys were dressed in
black almost kind of looking at dressed
like despite verse 5 from Mad Magazine
and you had to suck and get in an
elevator and on each floor there were
these bad guys and as you pass the floor
they'd be shooting at you from the right
it's books from the left and you had to
get all the way up to the top of the
building and get something and then come
back down again and the worst was when
you were going back down again and you'd
be shooting at the guy and the guy would
duck and he lay down on the floor and as
you went by when you couldn't raise your
gun up and it was just your head at
floor level he blow your [ __ ] brains
out I used to play that one I buy either
one of those I guess now I would I
wouldn't his [ __ ] waste of money but
how boy have we had a great time and I
got a killer picture of Dean in his
total [ __ ] rock star pose playing the
game
and I think he already tweeted it out so
if you look at Dean Del Rey's Twitter
thing you can find that [ __ ] so we did
that and I want to thank people at dr.
grins comedy club I went down there and
did a quick spot you know went up did
some jokes or whatever and it was funny
when Dean was up there he [ __ ]
started trashing this woman who sitting
in the front row because she wouldn't
shut up and I said the other comics go
they're going I'd like there's one of
those deals as a comedian you'll be on
stage and someone's talking and
commenting on your jokes and then you
don't realize most the crowd can't hear
and so you're kind of supposed to ignore
it I guess even though it's driving you
nuts so he just [ __ ] snaps and
trashes her and I was sitting in the
back of the club I said to the other
comedians it's like you know it's funny
we couldn't even hear what she said he
probably should have just kept going I
go I've made that mistake 20 thousand
[ __ ] times then I went up next and I
did the exact same thing exact same
thing and I [ __ ] trashed her and then
she got mad you know said she was
offended by some [ __ ] joke I did
about the troops of some [ __ ] like that
psych no it is it's no it is I know when
you gotta send it you [ __ ] egomaniac
but I looked at I said something to be
effective why would you think that you
have anything interesting to say was one
of those lines which was just really you
know
now they've said it out loud and that's
kind of gotten out of emotion to
ourselves really mean I went mean that's
what I did I went [ __ ] mean
so anyways oh by the way somebody tried
to scam me they tried to scare all
freckled we think it dealing with here
huh some [ __ ] rep bald Ralph Malph
[ __ ] [ __ ] where you are that
doesn't mean you can scam me though they
almost did if I wasn't so [ __ ]
paranoid I'm hanging in the hotel and I
get this phone call and I pick it up and
it's just this computer going out that's
saying that they were calling from Apple
and that there was a problem with my
iCloud and somebody might be breaking
into it and they go you know call this
number
blah blah blah blah blah oh my god you
got to be [ __ ] kidding me so I start
then they say the number twice I can't
remember it so I just start
guess and I punched in like out of the
you know ten numbers you know 1 888
whatever I got about 6 in and it
immediately starts dialing and I somehow
get connected now right there that
should have liked it me off that these
people are just fishing looking for
somebody to react to it so I dialed like
six other [ __ ] ten digits I needed
and then this guy's like a long there's
a bubble and I was like yeah you guys
just call well what is it's referring to
it's like you [ __ ] called me it's
about my soundcloud or whatever and they
go oh yes yes you have a security
problem but bum and I go well whose
[ __ ] fault is that I go why did you
guys set up the cloud if it wasn't going
to be like safe now you've exposed me
all this [ __ ] because what I [ __ ]
because I downloaded the royal blood
[ __ ] album now all of a sudden
somebody's going to drain my bank
accounts you computer [ __ ] I wasn't
cursing but I was flipping out then he
goes so sir we can help you we can help
you over the phone we just need to
access your computer
I don't need access my computer and the
guy just starts talking I go if I don't
do that over the phone and go sir this
is a very this is a secure [ __ ] bla
bla bla I go well how do I know what
cause you say so basically I wouldn't
[ __ ] do it just because I was looking
at I was looking at them like they were
legit but I was just like well you
already got hacked why the [ __ ] would I
go with you again why don't I just go to
the store so literally got to the point
I go sir this is this is secure ba ba ba
ba ba ba I just kept going like well I
don't even know who you are
you just FRA know you're one of the guys
[ __ ] trying to hack into my computer
dude I literally felt like I was in the
Bourne Identity you know when you don't
know who to trust
you don't you just [ __ ] yelling at
the other guy going you put your gun
down
you put your gun down first right so
finally he gives up home and he goes so
here's your case number and uh you know
I'll [ __ ] you know he said some dumb
[ __ ] been to Turkey or Jordan recently
like no no I saw the 34:30 on Len Bias
when he [ __ ] went one-on-one against
Michael Jordan
you call in Michigan you [ __ ] [ __ ]
so anyways he ends up transferring me
and it just [ __ ] hangs up and then
I'm like flipping the [ __ ] out so I
called the guy who produces my [ __ ]
show and he just goes why cuz yeah Apple
doesn't call anybody because nah man
that's just [ __ ]
so thank God I'm a paranoid jackass or I
might have let something happen there so
job just putting that out there like you
know I'm sure all you young guys know
what it is and you feel so smart and
you're going to shake your head and
laugh your ass off at me on Twitter
going like okay hey [ __ ] it
oh do you know I'm like it's 2017 oh I
learned that back in 2010 dead Jeff what
else did you learn how not to play a
guitar and then still call yourself a
musician I'll bill ah bill come on let's
not be the old guy here huh I got to be
honest with you
Del Ray played me some of that Skrillex
guy stuff and I [ __ ] really liked it
I thought it was way different than
anybody else and that's what I'm
learning whenever something new comes
out as much as your old ears listen to
it and say what the [ __ ] is that you
just have to know that there's going to
be the [ __ ] the Jimi Hendrix the
Richard Pryor the Tom Brady the James
Brown the [ __ ] with is going to be
you got to find out who that person is
of the thing that you listening to and
then you can judge it okay
it goes by sweater gun goes right back
to New York Pizza
all these [ __ ] dopes get off the
[ __ ] plane the first place that's his
famous New York Pizza they eat it and
then they go this Pizza sucks here it's
like no you didn't go to the right place
okay you didn't go to the right place
and DJ's are like New York's pizza in
that [ __ ] everybody thinks they can
do it you know everybody's claiming that
they're the real [ __ ] deal and
everybody saying they're famous
everybody's famous raid a [ __ ] DJ and
I actually I really like to [ __ ] I was
like you know what I could actually
[ __ ] get in the car and drive listen
to this [ __ ] especially at night like
there's great like drive-in songs like
the who eminence front who you ever want
win a bunch of [ __ ] money playing
poker
that's it just get you money leave get
in your car by yourself the [ __ ]
window down and you listen to that songs
you drive up to the desert
I'm Ted screaming what a top five
moments of your life oh [ __ ] you all
mold anyways what else what else do they
want so all did you guys watch all the
mayweather mcgregor
pressors as they call them overseas the
press conferences it's kind of the same
thing over and over again with Conor
McGregor he just kept going like what aw
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is wrong with you he
got on a [ __ ] track suit that form
Voltron thing was dumb and I loved when
he trashed him on that but I will tell
you this watching all of those people
showing up for a [ __ ] press
conference
they sold out the Barclays Center they
sold out with like the Maple Leafs play
I believe in Toronto the Staples Center
people showing up to watch a [ __ ]
press conference
I can tell you this cynical bill is
going to ruin the pay-per-view for you
those press conferences are going to be
better than the fight you know and the
[ __ ] people that are going to order
that goddamn fight are the same [ __ ]
people that slow down on the highway to
watch somebody change your [ __ ] tire
it's like it's just beyond it's beyond a
spectacle I think people go like that
you know I know it's a spectacle but you
know just I'm just going to watch it too
[ __ ] much ain't no getting [ __ ] in
the ass but I want to see what it feels
like
[Music]
dude that pay-per-view can go [ __ ]
itself do the riding on the same plane
over the [ __ ] London get the [ __ ] out
of here and all this [ __ ] McGregor gives
Mayweather there's one topic he
completely avoids because it would [ __ ]
with ticket sales which kind of makes
him part of the [ __ ] [ __ ] of that
whole thing you know what I mean it's
just get the [ __ ] out of my [ __ ] I've
given that guy enough [ __ ] goddamn
money given him enough [ __ ] money
I've gotten [ __ ] enough
I'm going to [ __ ] enough by that guy
was like it's professional boxers can't
lay a [ __ ] hand on them and I [ __ ]
nod not by the eighth round as he's poo
poo poo pointing him to [ __ ] death
now he's going to fight a guy who's not
even a bot who used to box I love they
use the box yeah there's a lot of people
used to do stand-up you want to see them
doing HBO special here's the bottom line
if they ever met each other in a bar and
started swinging McGregor would [ __ ]
kill him he'd taken to the ground and
then Mayweather would know what to do
so they've eliminated all of that we
know bill you've said that so I don't
know anyways maybe McGregor's I mean
Mayweather is ego maybe tries to knock
him out I'm just not I'm not going to
[ __ ] watch it I'm really not I think
what I'm going to do is I'm going to get
out on the highway when the [ __ ]
fight is on and just cruise down the
highway doing 90 miles an hour just
looking around going like this is what
it should be like like if I was running
[ __ ] this would be the level of people
that were in the world
I was joking on my hunt this weekend and
uh
Grand Rapids saying you know what I
would do if I was running [ __ ] on the
night of the Mayweather McGregor fight I
would turn all the Buffalo Wild Wings
into gas chambers if all those [ __ ]
mouth breathing morons that we're
jerseys you know with other men's names
on the bag also what I called it all of
those guys cuz he just gone all of them
gone and you'd watch I bet I bet the
mean the level of meanness on the
internet would go down you know these
life by the way these [ __ ] people now
who just sit there and they watch CNN or
Fox all day long and then they show up
to you and they just start vomiting out
all this [ __ ] fearful [ __ ] that they
just watched and then after they do that
and get you all stirred up they don't
even have the decency to offer a [ __ ]
solution all these [ __ ] morons it's
just like why would you sit there and
watch Fox News all daily that's all
you're going to do watch a little CNN
balance out your [ __ ] life keep
yourself level
[ __ ] what's-his-face my buddy was
telling me this weekend you know it's
good global warmers gonna get so hot you
know they're saying they're not gonna be
able to fly planes on LaGuardia and I
mean I'm thinking like how the [ __ ] am I
gonna be a comedian anyone you know and
then that was it he didn't offer any
[ __ ] solutions he just let me know
like hey in the future you not to be
able to do your job then I'm starting to
[ __ ] think about you know me my
family living out in the street all I
want to do is just I just want to play a
little asteroids you know if you don't
have a [ __ ] solution don't bring up
the goddamn problem okay like I brought
the Conor McGregor Mayweather right I
said it's a [ __ ] problem I gave you
you solution you drive on the highway 90
miles an hour
and you turn the Buffalo Wild Wings and
do a gas chamber see that see that I'm a
good guy everybody else is an idiot in
my world I'm the smartest person in the
room
sorry well we went for the [ __ ] do you
want for me you know watching my kid all
day today I was [ __ ] tired I can't
take from my goddamn past we're all not
watching now obviously while doing the
podcast but that's only because I curse
so much I'm trying not to do that in
front of her which I know I'm going to
fail [ __ ] miserably I get to take
something to being it being a dad is a
[ __ ] it really is a [ __ ] love it it's
the best thing about it is watching kids
shows I don't know if I'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] or whatever but I am legitimately
entertained we started watching cars
this morning it's tremendous I mean you
know it is I don't watch cartoons and so
[ __ ] long it's like the level of
animation on those things is crazy
like I think I saw one of those toy
stories one or two of them but you know
when you don't have a kid it's like you
know why would you go see one of those
unless you smoke weed like hey man let's
get high and go see [ __ ] toys man
right or you know you're dating a woman
they always like seeing them they're
cute I like the message and you end up
going there
and you just sitting there I just
[ __ ] them I remember is one of those
toy stories like they were going down
something and they walk this conveyor
belt they went into a pit of flames and
the level of [ __ ] anxiety that it
brought me I got like angry at the movie
like this is a [ __ ] kids movie I
shouldn't be feeling this way why do I
care so much about these goddamn toys
which is one of the reasons why I don't
watch movies it's because I I take the
[ __ ] ride you don't people watch
scary movies they go do it MOV didn't
scare me they all scare the [ __ ] out of
me because I just I take the [ __ ]
ride I never just I never [ __ ] pull
myself out and look around the theatre
going on suggest a movie there's no
reason to get this [ __ ] upset this is
stupid that's just an actor when he
takes they did I don't do that I get
sucked in and it's [ __ ] over it's
[ __ ] over and then I end up getting
freaked out and I walked in my car you
know and I'm thinking of the [ __ ]
Blair Witch is going to get me I think I
think I've battled long enough here
let's let's do a little bit of let's do
some advertising let's get to actually
the funniest part of the podcast me
trying to read out loud
all right frame bridge everybody oh you
know what frame bridge evidently is the
easiest way to custom frame your
favorite art and photos is it you can't
you know you know the easiest ways you
give it to your partner could you do me
a huge favor and handle this big pain in
the ass [ __ ] job but if you're
actually cool and you don't want to do
that to your wife or your husband or
your [ __ ] transgendered person
whatever I'm trying to be politically
correct here whatever the [ __ ] you're
living with maybe you're agoraphobic an
asexual split personality don't do it to
the other person in you okay did I cover
everybody without ever leaving your
house with their simple online ordering
process you can order a fully customized
piece in minutes here's how it works
go to frame bridge calm upload your
photo from your computer or directly
from your Instagram feed if you're in
the joinin lately or if you have a
physical item they'll provide secure
prepaid packaging so you can mail it in
for free
preview your photo online in any frame
or style choose your favorite or get
help for free free help from the
talented designers the expert team at
frame bridge will custom frame your item
in days not weeks or months and deliver
your finished piece directly to your
toward ready to hang now this was me I
end the copy here honestly how much
longer can you talk about photos in a
[ __ ] frame but not not these guys
they're going to keep going the best
part you may not have asked instead of
the hundreds you pay at framing stores
their prices start at just $39 $39 free
plus my listeners will get 15% off their
first order at frame bridge comm when
they use my code burr alright guess we
need to know how much it cost frame
bridge even offers a happiness guarantee
if for any reason you are 100 percent
satisfied with you order they'll make it
right well then you should have a
satisfaction guarantee not a happiness
we have a happiness guarantee that
you're not 100% satisfied that doesn't
make any sense
do you know hundred percent of happiness
right happiness guarantee if you for any
reason are 100 percent happy with your
order they'll make it right I know Jesus
give your personal experience using
framers I never [ __ ] used it I need
you guys I never know why I don't have
the [ __ ] photo I took the last 20
years I don't know where it is it's on a
hard drive in the back of my closet and
I took so many [ __ ] pictures a [ __ ]
like a what are you even use it for the
site the ease of order and how your
piece turned out and how easy and
affordable was get started today framing
your photos or art do they should have a
[ __ ] website useless cell phone pics
you know those ones you just have you
took a screenshot of something because
you need to remember a phone number and
then like months later you're scrolling
back trying to find that picture you
when you got on the hang glider and one
of the photos you got a scroll past is
good [ __ ] 1-800 number for the Smokey
Robinson CDs you know I don't would that
be funny to sit there and look at the
top 10 worthless cell phone photos of
the day then people do it on purpose
so probably cool for like a month all
right go to frame bridge calm and use
promo code BRR
you'll save an additional 15% off your
first order just go to frame bridge calm
promo code per frame bridge calm promo
code BRR
that's classic advertising read the last
time you do it you had that time frame
restart calm everything's going to be
alright alright he looks everybody
you're unique
you don't walk like everyone else talk
like everyone else show can't sleep like
everyone else so why is your mattress
one is your mantras ones on Google
because a truly customized mattress will
cost you five to ten thousand bucks
until now I can't believe that's a right
number
go to hell XCOM answer a few simple
questions and they'll run do you sleep
on your back or you sleep on your dick
and they'll run a 3d biomechanical model
of your body through their proprietary
algorithms they develop with the help of
the world's leading economic sand
biomechanic experts the result a robot
shows up to the door punches you in the
face through the mattress that you
ordered and becomes you sorry the most
comfortable mattress you've ever slept
on helix customers report a 30%
improvement in overall sleep quality and
for couples they customize each side of
the mattress that's the end of the
relationship right there you're starting
to build separate lives your mattress
arrives at your door in about a week and
shipping is 100% free that's why
everyone from GQ magazine to Forbes are
all talking about hellix sleep you have
a hundred nights to try it out if you
don't love it they'll pick it up for
free and you have a 100% refund no
questions asked go to helix sleep calm /
/ and get $50 off your order
that's hellix sleep calm / bark hey he
looks liek calm / / one of those
pronunciations is right oh my god
everybody it's Dollar Shave Club do
Dollar Shave Club is this smarter choice
why you might have asked you'll get a
great shave at a great price
conveniently delivered right to your
door you're going to be set for life kid
you no longer have to schlep to this
store buy cheap disposable ray
is that give you a cheap shave or spend
a fortune on raises with gimmicky
shaving technology you don't even
[ __ ] need and when you use Dollar
Shave club's executive razor with dr.
cavity the blade gently glides giving
you a smooth shave as you travel across
your bowl bag dr. Carver shave butter is
transparent for a more precise shape
helps prevent ingrown hairs and fights
razor bumps so in other words it works
for white people and black people make
the smart choice by going to do Ollie
shave club for a limited time new
members get their first month of the
executive razor with a tube of their dr.
Carver's shave butter for only 5 dollars
with free shipping after that
the razors are just a few bucks a month
that's 15 that's a $15 value for only 5
bucks there's no hidden fees and no
commitments cancel anytime you like you
can only get this offer exclusively at
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / / i [ __ ] love
those guys just for the simple fact that
it's just one paragraph they have
empathy for me I feel alright one more
can you guys handle me reading out loud
wink winc or is it wink it is winc
whiskey India November charlie when you
have a great clap when you have a great
glass of wine it enhances the moment
whether you're reflecting on the day or
with someone you love or just overly
explaining something to three people who
have been bored with you for 20 minutes
depending on drunk you are
wink understands this it's why they
started their company to give you access
to exceptional wines from around the
world so you have more of those moments
of being drunk around your children now
I'm just kidding nobody who drinks wine
is a women - women drink wine after they
put the kids down right let me pull it
out [ __ ] like the cork off like a
[ __ ] pirate and you know what god
bless them they deserve to do that just
try winked calm spelt T ry
WI MC calm try wink calm take a brief
palette profile quiz and
will recommend distinct and interest
interesting wines actually customized to
your palate to be shipped directly to
your door every month isn't it hilarious
that you can do this with alcohol you
can never do this with like crack
cocaine you know take a brief palette
profile quiz and we'll get you the crack
pipe that best fits your lips none of
your time is wasted fitting in a run to
the store or on your way home from work
or on your way to an event or gathering
no more time spent guessing what you
might like that's actually great there's
nothing worse as an adult when you go
over a couple's you know should we bring
anything now we're all good you know you
got to bring a bottle of wine then you
got to stop at the [ __ ] door though
that the store - pain-in-the-ass just
stock up on booze with try winked calm
because wink bases the blinds they said
they send you on your taste preferences
wink will even introduce you to new rare
and custom wines that are not available
anywhere else and tell you the story
behind each one join for free skip any
month cancel anytime and have 100%
satisfaction guarantee
so you never have to pay for a bottle
you don't like and right now wink is
offering listeners $20 off your first
order when you go to try wink calm / /
they'll even cover the cost of shipping
let's try wink calm spell t ry winc calm
/ / to get $20 off your first order plus
complimentary shipping
let's try wink calm / bar alright what
are we up to 34 [ __ ] minutes oh you
know what I don't even talk about the f1
race do you guys watch it did you check
it out Lewis Hamilton closing the gap
only down by one point catching up on
Sebastian Vettel what happened to the
Ferraris out there in [ __ ] Great
Britain
what was it Kimi räikkönen whatever his
[ __ ] name is
he's driving he's in third place he's
loving life for second place whatever he
was in his front tire Wow [ __ ] blows
out with like [ __ ] four or five laps
to go
and then he [ __ ] gets on the rating
of towns it like fffft when he goes up
for the [ __ ] front two tire right so
he's got to go when Vettel moves up he's
going to be on the podium as much as
[ __ ] Lewis Hamilton is going to pick
up 25 points he's going to pick up at
least [ __ ] 15 if not 18
who knows you know and all of a sudden
[ __ ] two laps to go his [ __ ] tire
goes up front left one right and then
all these towns you like mama me alright
and [ __ ] pedals all goddamn pissed I
think I have a I think I know who my
favorite [ __ ] driver is though I like
that however you say his first name
black belt it Valtteri Bottas
that guy that guy can [ __ ] drive
he went from 9th place all the way to
2nd place and I know I've talked about
Lewis Hamilton and these guys going from
[ __ ] you know 9th like
what's-his-face yesterday the Australian
[ __ ] dude they're bigger the happiest
guy in [ __ ] Formula One Jesus Christ
bye I swear to God offend all the
[ __ ] names in front of me you know
what is that raking in there's too many
arse
there's too many [ __ ] like crazy
[ __ ] the nerve of these people bleep
up from like other cultures is it was a
date is it Dave Dave [ __ ] Jesus I
only met the [ __ ] guy
I've only been rooting for him Daniel
Ricciardo there we go the [ __ ] it would
pop back into my head as much as those
guys have gone from like 19th to [ __ ]
you know 7th or 8th or 15th to whatever
it I think it's harder to go from 9th
all the way up to second because you get
into like the best of the best drivers
to [ __ ] go past driver number 5 for 3
to get all the way up to that start and
wait as far back as he did with the
Mercedes once again having a gearbox
issue that's what happens with Mercedes
they have a gearbox issue and they get a
five spot [ __ ] penalty and evidently
I don't know who the [ __ ] it is that's
supposed to be working on that [ __ ]
shock absorber on the front left-hand
side of the car or the fin or the
[ __ ] tire whatever the [ __ ] it is one
of those guys where the under routes
with the helmet on in the pit somebody
back there is getting a [ __ ] is
getting no pasta this week on the
Ferrari team so what's-his-face Vettel
was up by like I don't know how many
[ __ ] points I figure out what place
he came in I think he got like six or
eight points and he was up by like he
was up like 20 points before the race
started I can do the math here and by
the end of the race he was only up by
one
it's like a [ __ ] math test so Lewis
Hamilton got 25 points so he outscored
him by [ __ ] 24 so when he come in
10th place he got one point no that'd be
24 he got four points alright so he came
in he came in like eighth right he came
in eighth all right whatever why the
[ __ ] would you care so they got one more
race before they take the break in the
summertime like their like their lives
are [ __ ] great enough they're part of
like like literally 20 people who can do
this in the [ __ ] universe
alright they get to take the [ __ ]
summer off unlike these poor bastards
that play [ __ ] baseball who got to
pay like [ __ ] six to seven games a
goddamn week you know these guys get to
take the summer off granted they have to
still diet you know but you know even if
they have like a shake then they can
they can [ __ ] and get rid of it banging
a supermodel you know [ __ ] sweat it out
of them I mean their lives are
unbelievable lewis hamilton and [ __ ]
what's-his-face bow ties they both live
in monaco sümbül it's like it's not
enough that you know he's got the
private jet like these [ __ ] guys
lives are unbelievable
it's [ __ ] tremendous god bless him
hey what's going on with the [ __ ] the
other Red Bull team that's not Red Bull
the blue ones the [ __ ] what the hell
what the whether they be that the Toro
Rosso [ __ ] team whatever the [ __ ]
they're called Jesus Christ they were
doing their impression of the Force
India team [ __ ] slamming into each
other I love when that happens
I love that reminds me of that [ __ ] in
the movie Step Brothers they do unlike
the Formula One version of putting their
balls on Will Ferrell's drum kit
oh no he put it on the other guy's drum
kit that's right I don't know anyways
let's get to the [ __ ] questions this
week oh by the way all things comedy
zone Ari Shaffir is new double Netflix
special airs Tuesday July 18th both
double negative both both double
negatives children and double negative
adulthood will be available in one
90 countries it's incredible huh the
reach the sheer reach of Netflix all
right feminism everybody let's do some
[ __ ] leads here for the goddamn week
shall we I got 20 minutes left here in
this [ __ ] podcast
all right feminism bill on a recent
podcast when discussing stewardesses and
air travel you mentioned that you
sometimes thing I mean even say think
feminism is a way for ugly women to get
jobs that attractive women used to have
I said that why do you guys take
anything I say seriously you understand
I'm just riffing for a [ __ ] hour and
I'm trying to make you laugh by saying
ridiculously over-the-top things
somebody's going to write me in a few
weeks ago hey bill a few weeks ago in
your podcast you suggested turning
Buffalo Wild Wings in the gas chambers
on the night of the Mayweather McGregor
fight just to let you know I am apparent
I am NOT a fight fan but I do enjoy the
[ __ ] jalapeno balls whatever the [ __ ]
they're called at Buffalo Wild Wings and
what if I was there anyways uh I wonder
if okay you Ivan le I said that feminine
is a way for ugly women to get jobs that
attractive women used to have that's
[ __ ] hilarious I don't necessarily
believe that but there is an element of
truth to that like you know when they
always bitching like you know Hollywood
creates this impossible image of beauty
it's like no you can't you can't your
fear [ __ ] egomaniac I don't think
when I look at a Brad Pitt whoever the
[ __ ] guy is now Brad Pitt's like in
his 50s now so whoever the [ __ ]
shredded who's the guy from Saved by the
Bell Mario Lopez you know when I when I
look at him with his pigment and his
[ __ ] abs and all that I don't [ __ ]
go like this is an impossible [ __ ]
hell Jesus this is an impossible
standard for me to tilt all standard for
me to hold up to and therefore Mario
Lopez should be on [ __ ] TV anymore I
just understand that yeah you know one
on a good day maybe I'm a six okay
that's what I am
not everybody can bat cleanup in the
order okay if you [ __ ] bat Nate quit
your client and get on base that's it
maybe I do believe that on some level
anyways I wonder if you know that this
is actually Rush Limbaugh's undeniable
truth of life number 24 specifically
that feminism was established so as to
allow unattractive women to access
access to the mainstream society here's
the thing I'm saying this [ __ ] I'm like
90% joking there's always like an
element of truth that guy as far as I
could tell because I don't know what his
active it might all just be an act you
know so he can eat because he is in show
business so I have no idea it could just
be an act but if you actually truly
believe that I don't listen I don't
believe that okay feminism came about
because men were not allowing women to
pursue their dreams okay but like any
cause any cause for whatever reason
along the way a lot of the times you end
up becoming what the [ __ ] you were
fighting okay and that's not this unique
thought I realize that's a hacky thought
but it's [ __ ] true the level of
bullying that goes on on the internet
and trying to get people to get fired
and trying to create firestorms and
trying to trying to show the power of
women by a lot of times attacking people
who you're deliberately and knowingly
taking what they said out of context and
causing them to not have a [ __ ] job
it's [ __ ] reprehensible alright and
they in a lot of ways do the same
reptilian if the ends justify the means
corporate [ __ ] mentality just some of
the [ __ ] that is set out there um yeah
look I don't think that it's actually
that but sometimes I think it's that you
know there are jobs that you should only
get if you're good looking you know I
really believe that like like when you
did you know the first person that
they're going to [ __ ] walk in
the top of your order you got to go with
Rickey Henderson you know you got to get
somebody who's going to get on base you
know put the [ __ ] picture up you know
I feel like I can say this because of
how I look like if I ran a company I'm
not putting me on the front desk like
I'm the first person you're going to see
why would you do that we're trying to
make money here you know I know that I
schools over look in the mirror love
yourself but have a sense of humor about
yourself know that you're not perfect
and just know that it's okay and you
know a lot of times if you stare into
that [ __ ] and you have a sense of humor
about yourself you're fun to be around
how many times I call myself a pasty
bald freckled [ __ ] jackass telling
you you [ __ ] stare into it and you
[ __ ] age gracefully
all right you starting to lose your
[ __ ] hair you just shave you [ __ ]
head and just be that guy everybody's
like what the [ __ ] and then but you know
what you deal with then people thought
they respect you look at this guy came
down the pike he didn't even try to
shake it off he took the pitch right to
the side I had Darius be standing on
first base good for you you ugly bald
son of a [ __ ] right and this is the
thing so I know that they need ugly bald
son of a [ __ ] in movies and I'll just
audition for that at the end of the
[ __ ] day I'm in a movie
am I really going to complain you know I
feel [ __ ] [ __ ] bald freckled red
edge should be starring in more movies
it's like oh yeah you want to put your
money put your money where your mouth is
you go finance that [ __ ] movie yeah
in a lot of ways that's one of those
things where everybody should get like a
ribbon I mean I don't know what the
solution is but you like competition is
a good thing okay and the best you know
the best should should win right like
I'm all with it as far as everybody
should have the same opportunity but
after that go [ __ ] yourself whoever's
the best gets it
you know not like well we have enough of
these people or enough of those know who
are the [ __ ] best okay when we have
to keep doing that because at some point
if the aliens aren't already here
they're coming here and we we need to
have an all-star [ __ ] team not a team
that makes everybody feel represented
all right there we go I hope I explained
myself or you know I'll know if I'm
right if I don't get a call from the
Rush Limbaugh Show asking me if I want
to be a guest
all right brother acts feminine dear
Billy Boy yo relative relatively new fan
here I loved your mighty love your
material now to see live one day well
thank you before I start I want to say
that I don't care if my brother is gay
to each his own is my motto okay now for
the back story there you go that's what
I do you've established you've given
yourself credibility because you said
that you're a good person all right I'm
17 about to be a senior in high school
my brother is 11 and is about to start
middle school I feel like other kids
will view him as an easy target for a
few reasons first he doesn't have many
guy friends and he hangs out with a lot
of ladies second I do I tried to do
masculine things with him I played
baseball so I always asked him to play
catch with me and I even offered to
teach him how to place the sport he
usually says no when I try to do any
sort of physical activity with him he
rejects my request and just does his own
thing third his body language is quite
feminine he sits like a girl talks like
a girl and moves his hands like a girl
you know what I'm saying and the thing
that ladies and gay guys do with their
hands oh you know what I'm saying the
thing that ladies and gay guys do with
their hands when they talk my gut tells
me to sit down and have a talk with him
but I don't want to come off too blunt
and hurt his feelings then again that
could be what he needs I think if I tell
them what I'm thinking he'll just blow
it off just like me
he's very hot-headed sorry about the - I
personally blame his behavior on the
pacification of society over the past
few years and the very progressive
environment of modern day schooling he's
a good kid and he's got a good head on
his shoulders so I'm not worried about
anything else I'm just looking out for
him I don't want any [ __ ] messing
with him I used to get bullied so I know
how it feels what do you think
thanks for helping go [ __ ] yourself all
right I think you're 17 and I think you
love your brother and you're trying to
protect them is the deal do I mean your
brother is who your brother is you got
to accept that and I don't know how you
handle the bullying thing which is I
what I really think is what you see when
you look at your brother's like this
kids going to get the [ __ ] kicked out of
them
which is you know sad to say you know
hopefully not as much as when I was
coming up but yeah that is a that is a
it's a legit concern but I don't think
people are born how they're born okay I
don't know if this kid's gay or not I
don't know what but if he doesn't want
to play catch he doesn't want to play
catch and if he's hot-headed you know he
found he said he's a smart kid he's
hot-headed he knows what he wants so
just let him be himself and you support
him and there's no reason why this kid
he doesn't like to do physical [ __ ] I
wasn't saying take him down to a dojo
teach him how to [ __ ] somebody up and
the fact that he is effeminate if he
goes and [ __ ] somebody up that's going
to be humiliating for the other person
and then nobody else is going to want to
[ __ ] with them because they don't want
to get beat up by him Bruce Lee used to
do that Bruce Lee used I read this book
used to walk around in fact all
effeminate and then these guys would
come up and [ __ ] with them and then he
would kick the [ __ ] out of him people
asked him well why would you do they say
well if I just walked up like a regular
dude you know they got their ass kicked
they could get over it but if you know
they thought they got their ass kicked
by a [ __ ]
you know it stays with them and
unfortunately that is something with
guys if you know if people were more
progressive or whatever the [ __ ] word
is they wouldn't think that and they'd
just be like well it doesn't make a
difference if you're effeminate or
masculine if you can [ __ ] throw hands
over there
a couple of feetsies I can I can accept
the loss I listen I would just if
anything I would try to have a closer
relationship with my younger brother and
then I would ask him how his days are
going and I would just Lily ask him as
anybody at school [ __ ] with you or
whatever and if they are I don't know I
would go down and have a [ __ ] tow I
don't know if you could do that I don't
know what to do I don't know what to do
but that would all the brother that
would kill me
knowing that somebody could be [ __ ]
with my younger brother so I think you
come from a good place your ideas of you
know how to cure him of that are
understandable because you're 17 I don't
think it's society's fault I just think
that's just how he's born and I think if
you accept it he will accept it and
he'll keep a good feeling about himself
but unfortunately the bullying is going
to come and he's gonna have to learn how
to stick up for himself I mean that's
just the truth of it and there's all
kinds of things that you could do that
I'm not allowed to say in the podcast as
far as what he could do in those moments
because somehow I become this [ __ ]
bad person but uh I'm just going to tell
a random story here I'm ever child too
late Charlie Murphy trusted soul he told
me to do what to do if you ever go to
jail and I just be first like you know
not that I could still serve what you
just like yo this is what you do he goes
the first [ __ ] that steps to you
he goes you just turned into a wild
animal frothing at the mouth and you
just [ __ ] swing for the fences and
everybody you know what I'm
oversimplifying what the [ __ ] he said
and you know that's just a story he told
me that has nothing to do with what I
just [ __ ] read okay I want to do that
so I stay free and clear I don't know
what to tell you buddy alright let him
be who he is and you know I would watch
some MMA events with them and maybe
we'll want to learn how to [ __ ] do it
I don't know
I don't know because I watched some cool
videos of some kids that were way out of
their own weight class
it's one [ __ ] kid [ __ ] this kid app
jumped up put him in a [ __ ] armbar
this kidding you know what the [ __ ] to
do
maybe that you can help them out with
that but uh yeah I would let go of all
that other [ __ ] that you're going to
[ __ ] i mean if like you of yo who you
are i mean if somebody want you to go
out in the driveway needs to learn how
to twirl a baton you just would still be
you but you know how to twirl a baton i
don't think it would change how you
walked or behaved or who you hung out
with your wired how you wired
alright girlfriend wants to move back to
her home that's like those [ __ ]
people that we know they would try to
cure gay people you know they think that
they could like it's like they have the
mumps or something girlfriend wants to
move back to her home country alright
hey bill hill if the guy took the
woman's last name in marriage that's
funny alright longtime listener
first-time advice Sica I live in London
I met my girlfriend online a year and a
half ago she's 25 and I'm 24 she's from
Switzerland see this is what happens now
all these [ __ ] dating apps fun fact
about Switzerland they have enough
nuclear bunkers to accommodate their
entire population yeah that's because
they're so close to [ __ ] Germany they
moved here a few years ago to get a
music she moved here a few years ago to
get a music degree and graduated
graduated last year she was going to
move in with a friend a few months ago
but her best friend did a 180 at the
last second so we decided to move in
together as we enjoy each other's
company here's the [ __ ] part she always
said that she misses her family and her
friends a lot which is of course
understandable but recently she's been
mentioning that she wants to move back
to Switzerland once our lease is up next
year I completely get why she want to do
this she doesn't have many friends here
as many of her college friends have
moved back home the thing is I have
established an established career here
and I don't want to leave my friends a
job behind to go move to a country where
I
don't speak the language I've tried but
there are hardly any courses for Swiss /
German and the market for my skills is
much smaller I'm a magician in academic
tutor Jesus is a [ __ ] combo whenever
she brings it up I answer with very
variations of well we'll cross that
bridge when we come to it but I'm pretty
sure I'm never going to come around to
the idea she has made the point a couple
of times that this would be me choosing
my career and friends over her which
makes it sound worse than it is what
should I tell her thanks - go [ __ ]
yourself well she's choosing her country
and her family over you so I would say
nicely listen you keep saying that this
is me choosing my career and you know
which is what you say my and friends
over her do you know that feeling you
have when you live here in London that's
what I'm going to feel like when I'm in
Switzerland do you want me to feel that
no well good I don't want to feel that
either
so one of us has to make a sacrifice
here are you willing to live here and if
she says no then you have to be willing
to live there and if you're not willing
to do that then you guys need to break
up it's simple as that simple as that
I would I would [ __ ] that's it dude
you know you got a [ __ ] goddamn kids
today and [ __ ] swiping left and next
thing you know yeah my girlfriend lives
in [ __ ] Bangladesh and she's really
missing some of the food over there and
I you know I [ __ ] you know whatever
the [ __ ] I do over here I mean these are
these are like modern-day relationship
[ __ ] problems yeah that's it one of
you guys has to move but don't let her
guilt you and she's not choosing her and
a friends you're doing what she's doing
you're living where you want to live
next to the people you love and you
can't get mad at her for wanting to do
the exact same thing all right but you
know she's trying to mind [ __ ] you know
for me I do feel like you're choosing
this go [ __ ] yourself all right well
go back home then send me some
chocolates well bang every once in a
while we'll meet in Paris how about that
that's it I don't want to tell you all
right girlfriend you came to my place
not the other way around
girlfriend's belly hangs past her tits
oh Jesus hey there bill hey there Billy
Willy freckle cheeks
I love the podcasts especially when you
and Nia do the podcast I know and I got
to get around here more but it's just
like when I do what she has to watch the
kid and the other way around all right I
got a problem that I'm hoping you and me
and may be able to help you with I love
my wife of seven years dearly we have
fun together make each other laugh etc
she's my best friend
we're in her early 30s have no children
and our very affluent crushing it except
for the sex the sex is bad because we
have become fatty fat fat we've been
together for a decade and this has only
become a problem over the past six
months
I'm 511 and 240 with a lot of muscle and
a lot of fat
she's 5'4 and 200 and has no muscle mass
I'm ashamed to say that even though I
love her fiercely she's no longer
physically attractive to me well I mean
what the [ __ ] I mean just being honest
I'm sure you're not as attracted to her
although you did give yourself some
props for having a little bit of muscle
you didn't quite say you as big a mess
I'm ashamed to say that he okay she
probably feels the same fact he said
that she probably feels the same she
used to be 140 tops and was curvy in all
the right places I used to be cut like a
Greek god our sex life was amazing she'd
have 1 2 3 orgasms Jesus Christ every
time we had sex
1 2 3 times 4 weeks and now maybe we
have sex once a month she can't climax
anymore because she gets too tired
changes over the past six weeks I've cut
10 pounds in exercise six times a week
I'm trying but I have a long way to go
she isn't trying to eat right and is not
interested in exercising with me
I know sex tends to dwindle over time
but I'd like for us to be in good enough
shape that we don't need a nitroglycerin
pill every time we try to do the dirt
any advice would be much appreciated
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself you have to
sit down and have an honest conversation
with her okay I would leave the sex life
out of it it's just like she's not going
to live long
all right at five four two hundred
pounds maybe you could start by going
for quote romantic walks and you hold
her hand and then you try to pick up the
pace and drag how long I would just yeah
I would talk to her about it and if she
chooses not to get in shape then I I
would not alter what you're doing I
would go back to being the Greek god
that you were and if she doesn't want to
get in shape then you know what are you
supposed to do watch her eat herself
into an early [ __ ] grave you're
supposed to be with somebody that you're
not sexually attracted to anymore I mean
that that's fair man if somebody puts on
almost like she put on almost half her
body weight I mean that's not that's not
fair it's not fair to yourself and it's
not fair to the person you're in you got
to be making an effort to still look
good you know when people have a
tendency men and women to do that to
become you know you know just walking
around [ __ ] shitty looking clothes
just being a Tubba [ __ ] and it's just
like that whole you should accept me for
whatever I am that means I'm going to be
the least of who I could be nobody ever
says that when they're the best yeah I'd
like to accept you [ __ ] going to the
goddamn gym same way you'd like me to
not [ __ ] have my belly hanging down
past my junk yeah I'd have a
conversation with a just sit down hey
you know what maybe my beautiful
daughters asleep maybe up Mia can come
in and help hang on a second let me hit
pause you can't do it you can't do it
sorry sorry to get you goddamn hopes up
so just know that that you just got
advice from a guy so what I would do is
I would ask a woman in your life not her
advice on how to how to drop in okay
because this is one of these
relationship conversations it's like
when a spaceship is re-entering the
atmosphere or the Space Shuttle that if
it wasn't at the right [ __ ] angle you
know well you lost a couple of those
[ __ ] shingles on the bottom you could
[ __ ] burn up on re-entry alright
did I really have to bring up that
tragedy to make my point I don't know
maybe I didn't all right girlfriend has
severe halitosis Jesus Christ the women
are getting destroyed you ladies ladies
you got it right in next week okay you
got it right in next week okay
stop being sweethearts and tell me what
the problem is with the guys this is
this is not fair and balanced like fox
news's or CNN
I love that chick that cried on CNN the
one with the Mary Lou Retton haircut
when Trump got elected it's just like
there was one of most unprofessional
journalistic moments I've ever seen in
my [ __ ] life how did we go from
Walter Cronkite to that like I literally
know who you voted for you're not a
journalist all right
hey there op-ed piece all right
girlfriend has severe halitosis dear
Billy batts I saw you perform at
hilarities in the land the worst [ __ ]
nickname the land the land of what Jesus
Christ that's so [ __ ] bad and you had
me in stitches please come back the land
they had t-shirts back there defend the
land do you know for half a second in
Boston they say they lose people calling
it the bean don't do that Beantown was
bad enough we don't make beans there
anymore anymore that Porchester still
makes [ __ ] lifesavers although Grand
Rapids still makes furniture okay
anyways I'm 23 year old man and recently
began dating a girl I met on a dating
app we've been on two dates and she has
bad breath dumper
Jesus Christ over [ __ ] do you care it's
not your problem anyways I've been on
two dates so far and they both went
great we went to a couple of museums
well how far away were you standing from
you standing there going is that her
breadth of the artifacts is that her
breadth of that [ __ ] woolly mammoth
statue that they dug out of the [ __ ]
ice 2,000 years ago
anyways Love Actually movie minimas from
[ __ ] four billion BC go [ __ ] yourself
all right we have a good conversation in
this great chemistry overall but when
she smiles the sight and smell indicates
years of not brush
flossing dude I don't even know the fact
that you need advice on this
there is thick dark yellow buildup along
her gum line oh my god I'm going to puke
and she talks loud so her breath travels
a long way kissing is difficult to enjoy
oh my god
yo this is gross I almost just gagged
there I almost just gagged there - what
kind of [ __ ] low self-esteem do you
have what is my advice either break up
with her or take her to one of those
self-power washes car wash things and
tell her to smile and [ __ ] blaster
right in the [ __ ] grill jesus [ __ ]
christ that's the most disgusting visual
oh my god what the [ __ ] what is my
advice I don't know what you know what
my advice is they should make a stamp
for you because you're a goddamn Saint
oh my god kissing is difficult Oh
oh my god I think I gotta walk this one
off buddy there's plenty of [ __ ] fish
in the [ __ ] sea jesus chronicon it's
like I'm gonna speak to that fish that's
like having a goddamn eel going along
your goddamned gum lines I'm sorry guys
like I don't know why yeah dude I would
just that that's it it's over I did
there should be no no I mean yeah
hanging there with this one what the
[ __ ] do you say hey what are you doing
Thursday night nothing you want to go to
the dentist
[Music]
let's get his or her cleanings oh my god
dude if if that looks like that what is
what is the [ __ ] basement going to
look like dude oh my god
oh my god hey god bless you do ya I get
her to a dentist however the [ __ ] you
bring that up I don't know some
questions are beyond me all right
Jesus Christ all right that's the I've
never had to stop reading an email
before I haven't done that I haven't
done come that close to puke and since
Opie and Anthony the baby bird when I
was in that [ __ ] room and I still to
this day cannot tell that story without
[ __ ] gagging and coughing and if you
puke easily do not [ __ ] go look up
Opie and Anthony baby bird all right
that's it
that's the podcast go [ __ ] yourselves I
will check in on you on Thursday I am
back to watching a little bit of
baseball I did miss the Yankee milk I
was working the whole weekend I think
the Yankees got the better of us I know
we did win one game Yankees are in third
and the [ __ ] devil race I'm moving up
there only half a game out so I'm going
to try to watch for playing the [ __ ]
in Toronto Blue Jays Bam Bam Bam Bam
[ __ ] Toronto Blue Jays knew that was
my reference to whatever that [ __ ]
song is by Rush that is the Morse code
YYZ for Toronto's Airport somehow they
came up with a guitar riff for that all
right
that's something Kevin Murphy would try
to do on emphasis of family huh season
two on Netflix look at that coming out
of that disgusting story promoting his
show telling you to go [ __ ] yourselves
I'll check in on you on Thursday